First contributors to poverty are,
well,
it's not so good to have a low Iq.
You know,
people don't like the idea of Iq because
it seems so arbitrary,
you know,
have a high Iq.
Well it's not like you deserve it.
Exactly.
It's your setup that way pretty much
right from the beginning.
It's very,
very,
very stable.
You can make a high Iq person stupider
by not educating them up to the level of
their possibility,
but taking someone who has a low Iq and
trying to raise that.
It's like if you can figure out how to
do that,
well you know it's Nobel prize time for
you because people have tried that a lot
and most recently with those,
you know,
Luminol lumosity games and that sort of
thing.
And the evidence that those produce
anything other than brilliant
performances on the lumosity game itself
is basically zero.
We haven't been able to figure out how
to see because intelligence is across
domain phenomena and you can get really
good in a single domain by practicing
like mad and what you'd want is to
practice like mad in a single domain and
hope that it generalizes to other
domains.
That's the holy grail of intelligence
increase.
It's like,
no,
no one's done it.
People claim it,
but the claims never hold up and people
have been trying for a long time to do
it and they haven't been able to do it.
And
differences in Iq really make a
difference.
You know,
I mean you guys,
average Iq is probably one slash 25.
One 30 ad at 1:15.
You're at the 85th percentile and 1:15
would barely get you going for you.
For Harvard University,
1:30,
you're probably graduate school
material,
you know,
1:45.
You're up there at the range where you
can probably do pretty much whatever you
want.
Although as you get smarter,
the scatter between your abilities
increase.
So you might have a very high verbal Iq
but not be so good at mathematics or the
other way around,
but it's a massive contributor to
lifetime success.
And I don't know what to do about that.
I mean why do smart people make more
money?
Well they get to where the edge of
production is faster.
So if you have a thousand people and you
rank order them by ICU,
the smart people are going to come up
with a new ideas first and they're gonna
have more ideas and they're going to
strategize better.
And you know,
with an Iq of 90,
which is 15 percent of the population,
you think about that 15 percent of the
population.
That's pretty much the threshold for
reading instructions and being able to
follow them.
So you know,
and our society is increasingly
sophisticated.
So it's by no means obvious.
You know,
the Liberals Think,
well society is unfair because there's
unemployment and the Conservatives think
while there's a job for everyone,
but none of them think,
well,
there are massive,
massive,
massive differences in people's ability
far greater than anyone realizes.
And that poses a structural problem.